it's great to welcome to the program
today Sven Brinkman who is a professor
of psychology at the University of
Aalborg Denmark also author of books
including stand firm and the joy of
missing out spend it's really great to
speak to you today well I'm glad that
you invited me thank you
so let's talk a little bit about the joy
of missing out and sort of the other
side of that which is the fear of
missing out or FOMO as many Americans
now as sort of understand the term first
and foremost what are we really
describing when we talk about the fear
of missing out what's happening sort of
psychologically that influences people
yeah I mean the fear of missing out is
sort of a mentality that we have
developed in our consumer society I
would say with a constant doubt about
what we are doing what we are consuming
what we're buying who we are with in
marriages and relationships our jobs no
matter what we do we can post the
question to ourselves is this the right
thing for me and that you know gives
this fear the question am I missing out
on something that is more important that
that could potentially you know be
important to me realize my inner
potentials to to grow as a person or
something like that and in addition we
have developed as we all know now
technologies digital technologies in
particular social media that enable us
to access almost anything all the time
our relationships new use knowledge
about all sorts of things so all these
things taken together really gives us
this fear of missing out in the you know
short term but also in the longer term
in in our lives and it's deeply
dissatisfying to us it makes us unhappy
it makes us miserable and it's really
difficult to do something about because
it's
so ingrained in our culture and in our
technologies so I want to get in a
second to the way in which modern
technology is making this worse but
before we do that thinking back a little
bit is there any way that this fear of
missing out might have at some point in
human history been some kind of an
evolutionary advantage is that a
possibility yeah it certainly is it's
always a bit risky to speculate about
what life was like 200,000 years ago in
East Africa and you know we have all the
myths of evolutionary psychology
I mean I'm absolutely certain that we we
come from East Africa so to say but it's
not given how much we can actually take
from the knowledge of human beings as a
species and conclude about current life
today but I guess you're right that you
know our activities as explorers of this
world what's around the next hill is an
important evolutionary motor if you will
and of course this was developed in
times when resources were scarce where
we had to struggle and fight to to
obtain goods
and-and-and you know food and all sorts
of things that we need to survive but
now all these things are not scarce at
least not in most parts of the world we
have plenty of resources and I'm not
just talking about food but all sorts of
products knowledge is you know consumer
goods of all kinds so the problem is
really something else
it's how to develop the art of
self-restraint the art of missing out
and saying no to all these invitations
that we're constantly faced with yeah so
I mean like in my professional life at
several years ago I would basically say
yes to everything part of it was the
fear that whatever I turned down was
going to be like the
big break the opportunity to sort of get
to the next level and over time
partially because of the growth of my
program but also because I've just kind
of developed as a person I'm much more
comfortable saying no to things but what
I think might have been useful to me
seven or eight years ago would have been
some kind of a system to better that
evaluates when should you say yes and
when should you say no so like what what
might be an infrastructure that people
could apply to their lives to better
decide what it makes sense to do and
what it makes sense to pass on yeah no
this is an extremely important question
in my view we see now all sorts of
programs like you know simple living 10
or 15 years ago it's now being
rehabilitated we have Marie Kondo yes
talking about decluttering your life we
have books about you know the art of
saying no and so this has become quite a
trend and I think it's important I think
we should listen to these voices because
they really do speak to something
important in our times but what I would
like to see and what I hope will happen
is that we discuss these things with
some sort of ethical foundation with
some sort of you know value basis and
just to give one example and I I don't
mean to say anything you know about
Marie Kondo but the question she wants
us to pose when we pick up our objects
is does it spark joy in me and now this
is a good question in a way but what if
this joy is momentary or what if it
doesn't spark join me now but it might
tomorrow or I might have other reasons
to keep this object maybe because it
represents some symbolic value related
to my family or my history of whatever I
think we can only answer these questions
and develop the system that you rightly
longed for in a way if we understand
that humans have commitments we have
obligations and and these are
applications and commitments are
basically what structure or should
structure our lives if we are to develop
this art of self-restraint as I like to
call it it's it's not just a matter it's
not it's not just a matter of doing as
little as possible and saying no to all
sorts of things
it's about as I see it moderation
Palin balancing between too much on the
one side and too little on the other and
I really think that you know ethics
moral philosophy can help us arbitrate
and navigate in these matters one of the
terms that I've discussed before with my
audience is the the term hedonic
adaptation which is often applied to the
cost of one's lifestyle in other words
if you're used to a $50,000 a year
lifestyle and then you get a raise to
$100,000 and everything in your life is
adjusted to go with $100,000 lifestyle
at a certain point you will that will
become your new baseline and you will
not really experience any subjective
well-being that is different from the
$50,000 a year lifestyle does that term
apply to the fear of missing out and the
idea that if you start doing much more
that becomes your baseline and you don't
really feel any better yeah absolutely
and I do discuss this a bit in the book
the fact I should say that we strive for
something we we might obtain it and then
we get used to it and we just develop a
new baseline of happiness or contentment
or subjective well-being that seems to
be part of the human condition and now
we talked earlier about our evolutionary
past and in evolutionary terms this is
highly useful because it means that if
we experience some trauma some loss and
tragedy we actually most of us quite
quickly bounce back to the baseline
level and that's quite good for us so we
can keep on living and and in producing
and and you know the nurturing our
offspring and so on but it's not good
news when we talk about
peak experiences you know joys and and
good surprises like winning in the
lottery and stuff like that because
those joys are just as momentary and we
will quickly you know fall back to some
baseline of happiness and then we might
begin to wonder is something wrong with
me I just won the lottery I just got the
job that I wanted my girlfriend just
agreed to marry me and and I might be
happy for a week or two and then
everything is back to normal and I think
it will be very difficult to break free
from this hedonic treadmill as some
people also like to call it but I think
at least we can realize that it's a fact
of human nature it's a basic fact of our
psychology and then we might be content
you know we might not you know explode
with despair when realizing that why do
I not have these you know huge bursts of
happiness with all these good things
have happened to me well because that's
just life most of our of our lives we
live in some sort of middle gray area
concerning happiness and that's just as
it should be so maybe we shouldn't focus
as so much on you know super happiness
the subjective well-being maybe we
should focus more as I said before on
values on ethics on what is meaningful I
think that is a much more useful and
practical approach to life trying to
figure out what is meaningful how to
nurture your relationships how to live
up to the obligations we have to other
people and doing important projects in
our lives and then from time to time we
will feel these you know bursts of
happiness and joy but more as a side
effect I'm very suspicious that we can
you know chase these peak experiences of
happiness directly I think when they
appear they appear as side effects of
you know truly meaningful human
activities but this is mainly what my
book is about it has become very
difficult
to focus on these meaningful human
activities because of the fear of
missing out because of all the noise
that we hear you know all the
invitations we get from social media
from commercials in this consumer
society that we have created for
ourselves so in in the sort of limited
time that we have left can you now get
specifically into how social media and
the sort of scrolling social web sites
like Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
are worsening this problem yeah it's
sort of a technology designed like so
much else in our consumer societies to
to make us dissatisfied with what we
have we can never say when we scroll
down a you know Facebook feed or
something like that now I know enough
now I don't have to know anything else
because there's always something else to
see to you know to click to like to
explore and so it's really designed to
make us unhappy with what we haven't
what we see and to go and hunt more and
that is you know exploiting the general
mechanism that that we have as humans
and that we have seen in the past you
know 200 years really being articulated
and developed with consumer society that
if you're happy with what you have if
you're satisfied you really suffer from
you know advice it used to be a virtue
to be able to say well I'm happy I'm
content but if you're happy and content
then you no longer you know feed into
the machinery of the industry and so on
and so you need more you need something
else and yes the social media and the
digital technologies are simply just a
very visible symptom of that I remember
one ad from you know Intercontinental
Hotel the the you know big hotel chains
of hotel and I said you can't have a
favorite place until you've seen them
all and this is like the poetry of
capital
right it really tells us something true
in in quite a poetic form but also
something quite tragic because the
message really is you can never have a
favorite place because you can never see
them all and try to translate that into
jobs into life projects into
relationships you can never have a
favorite partner until you've had them
all well obviously that's meaningless
but maybe that's what we are thinking
because it's what we have been taught to
to think when developing this fear of
missing out we've been speaking with
Sven Brinkman who is professor of
psychology at the University of Aalborg
Denmark also author of the book stand
firm and the joy of missing out spend
really a pleasure having you on thank
you it was a pleasure to talk to you